you know there's a lot of comic book tv
shows that are out there there's jessica
jones and luke cage there's daredevil
season two which was better than one or
three
there's loki there's wanda vision
hawkeye
all that stuff but every single one of
those marvel tv shows dc tv shows the
whole nine yards they all suck
compared to heroes season one now i
don't know how many of you guys out
there
ever saw heroes when that show came out
i remember when that show first came out
they were doing a lot of trailers and
everything for it you guys remember the
trailer or the trailer for heroes it was
the uh it was hayden panettiere whatever
is a cheerleader she was at like the top
of some
thing in a construction site like a
half-finished building she jumped off
she dislocated her elbow and like just
smashed her face and it healed and she's
just like my name's claire bennett and
this is attempt number whatever like
those little trailers like they were
just so amazing right here's the thing
for those of you guys who never saw
heroes one i would suggest you watch
season one and then stop all the seasons
after that were garbage but i would
suggest you watch season one although
the villains were cool do you guys
remember the villains they had when they
were on they were like the level five
villains like the really really
dangerous villains you had the one guy
who could create black holes like
literally create like vortexes that was
nuts you had knocks who could absorb
people's fear and it like amplified his
physical strength it was really really
cool right you had all these different
guys who were out there but heroes
season one
that show was phenomenal right it was so
great because from beginning to end it
was non-stop like suspense and it was
wildly interesting so here's the deal
right let's let's talk about this let's
talk about this show those are guys who
who are foolish enough to say i don't
want to watch it let's talk about this
show right what you had here is you
basically had this idea that you had all
these characters who had different
powers so peter petrelli was actually an
empath he was a mimic he could duplicate
the powers of anybody he saw and then
there came a point when he didn't even
have to be in their proximity all he had
to do was think about them and then he
could use their powers he had other
stuff too other characters that were out
there ali larter's character and so on
and so forth but for the core basis of
this story all we really knew is that
you had a point where peter petrelli was
visited by a guy named hiro nakamura now
here in nakamura this guy was amazing he
was like he was like the fan favorite of
the show because he was basically this
japanese dude who was kind of nerdy and
had the ability to manipulate time he
could travel back and forth through time
he could freeze time he was arguably the
most powerful character in the entire
show and so there came a point when
peter petrelli in the present day was
visited by a future version of hiro
nakamura who was just like you he's like
you look different without your scar and
stuff like that he's like but you have
to save the cheerleader from siler now
siler was the overarching villain of the
show and the one thing i never liked
about heroes is that they revealed the
identity of styler i wish he had just
stayed this mysterious character because
those guys never saw heroes for like the
first half of the show you never see
seiler's face you see it's like a
silhouette sometimes you kind of see
bits of it like once they officially
cast zachary quinto as cyler you
actually like you realize it was him but
all you would see was like his beard
right or you would see like his ear or
something like that but for the most
part he was just silhouetted but he was
this overarching guy and what he was
doing was traveling around killing
people and taking their powers it was so
cool he was just collecting people's
abilities like seiler so i still say to
this day siler god i love that show
siler is was one of like the absolute
best villains in any comic book show
ever like even in comics imagine what it
would have been like if seiler was a
villain in like dc comics he's just like
killing superheroes and taking their
powers
then it was amazing but like hero
nakamura is like you have to save him
from siler you have to go find isaac you
have to go find the painter and so it's
literally this cat and mouse game where
like they're trying to find isaac and
then eventually trying to find the
cheerleader all that kind of stuff and
like isaac has these paintings where the
city of new york gets destroyed
different things like that and so it's
just like like what in the world is
going on like basically the whole idea
is like the end times are coming like
some of them is going to take place
where the whole of new york is going to
be obliterated like literally just wiped
out in like what's essentially a nuclear
explosion like a detonation of sorts and
then you get like these really cool
moments here and there so like you have
a character called the haitian the
haitian was amazing he could shut down
people's powers because oh my god the
first time you realized what he could do
it was when he shut down the powers of
um
oh my god what was his name the cop you
guys remember the cop the guy who could
read minds he was like oh he was like
the nicest guy but like he could just
never catch a break and like his wife
was cheating on him and stuff what was
that guy's name matt parkman that's what
it is matt parkman man
man let me tell you something dude there
comes a point i think it's in season two
although maybe it's in season one when
they come across matt parkman's dad it's
nathan petrelli peter's brother and matt
parkman and you think that like uh matt
parkman's dad is like this relatively
reasonable and gentle guy and like his
powers are basically the same as matt's
but they're far more advanced but he
basically like locks matt and um and
nathan patrelli in their own heads and
walks away and it's just it's crazy how
powerful he was just this ridiculously
powerful telepath but matt parkman oh my
god i love matt parkman but you end up
having this moment where basically his
ability to read minds just shuts off
right well it kind of fades out and then
it goes away and all you see in the
corner is this guy called like the
haitian and you don't know anything
about it but then you also have horned
rim glasses guy you don't know anything
about him at first he's just this this
guy who's like obviously shady he's not
really the villain but maybe he is kind
of the villain but seiler is the main
villain so you're kind of wondering
what's going on with this guy and so
matt parkman like wakes up in the middle
of this quote-unquote procedure well
they're basically documenting his powers
and learning how they work and so on and
so forth and then eventually he's let go
the like like the haitian and horn rim
guy end up catching nathan petrelli
right now at this point in time nathan's
running for like political office like a
senator or something like that so it's
no small thing to snatch this guy up now
the whole time this is it's one of the
best moments in the whole show the whole
time
nathan is just this dude who never
believes peter because peter is like
just discovering his powers and he's
telling nathan things like he had
dreamed that he had the ability to fly
and stuff like that and like he actually
flew and so on and so well he's like
he's like i really did fly and like
nathan's like look dude like whatever
because peter's been like historically
irresponsible and so he's like whatever
peter like i don't have time for this
i'm trying to run a campaign like their
their mom is there which their mom turns
out to be an amazing character in the
show but it's like all these different
things so eventually like horn horn room
glasses guy in the haitian they finally
get a hold of nathan nathan wakes up in
the middle of everything and like
escapes right he goes running through
this compound he ends up at this fence
and they're like there's no means of
escape and he just takes off into the
air and flies and that's when you
realize peter gained the ability to fly
from nathan and nathan's been hiding it
this entire time it was so crazy it's
just like like i remember when that
happened i was like what nathan can fly
no way it was it was a craziest thing it
was the craziest thing right so the
there's like there's all these different
themes like you do have that one guy i
can't remember his name but basically he
was a walking talking nuclear reactor he
could let off like insane amounts of
nuclear energy and so what ends up
happening over the course of the show is
you have the moment when finally like
peter petrelli catches up to hayden
peninsula right catches up to the
cheerleader in odessa texas like she's
at her prom and all that kind of stuff
and so siler shows up there at the same
time because there was this this
painting that had been drawn by peter
when he had come across isaac and
basically copied isaac's powers where he
had drawn these different scenarios at
like the cheerleaders high school and
stuff like that and they were all kind
of clues they had to piece together like
i'm supposed to be there and this is how
things are gonna happen so like seiler
shows up at the same time like okay so
here's the thing back then it was crazy
because peter confronts tyler and it's
like the one thing you've wanted to see
over the course of the show so far man
man let me tell you something there's
like this telekinetic battle that
happens between the two because then you
learn that siler has like telekinesis
and his powers up to that point are like
ambiguous like he would be there one
minute and then disappear the next so
it's like okay i guess he can move at
super speed he had killed one guy who
basically had the ability to freeze
things then you knew he had like the
power to free stuff you didn't
necessarily see him use those powers all
the time it was just the victims that he
had killed you learned about their
powers and realized this guy had those
powers so by the time siler had shown up
at the high school and peter petrelli
confronted him seiler probably had
something like 10 or 11 different powers
it was nuts right it was it was crazy
and so what you get is you get what's
basically like this five year time skip
in the show where they jump forward five
years and show you what the future looks
like and one of the crazy things that
happens if i remember i think this isn't
season one not gonna swear to it but i
think this isn't season one and
essentially like once tyler's identity
is revealed and all this kind of stuff
what you end up learning is that nathan
petrelli successfully became president
of the united states and the guy seemed
a little shady right like drunk on power
and all that kind of stuff and so then
you also had things like peter patrelli
who had basically gone underground you
had um yeah this this was in season one
because matt parkman becomes the head of
the department of homeland security
after losing his family and like the
detonation in new york because that
actually happens and new york gets
destroyed and so he he's just like this
terrible person right just this really
cold-hearted son of a [ __ ] it's crazy
but you also have hiro nakamura who's
like routinely on the run and basically
the cast of the show at least those who
survived are always just kind of on the
move and trying not to get caught and so
there comes a point when the cheerleader
is discovered and the cheerleader is
basically taken to nathan petrelli and
it's like this really really cool moment
because there's there's a point like
something happens i can't remember
exactly what it is but like she she's
talking to nathan in the white house and
he's talking about how special he is and
he was like i'm i'm the leader of the
free world right like i'm the most
special person there is and something
happened some kind of an argument she
goes to walk away and she gets frozen in
place
and then literally like the top of her
head starts cutting and that's when you
realize it's siler that seiler had
basically killed a woman who had the
ability to duplicate like who was like
mystique from the x-men she could copy
the form of other people that siler had
killed nathan petrelli had been
pretending to be nathan petrelli this
whole time presumably i think after
nathan became president and then
basically killed claire he killed the
cheerleader and finally after all this
time which is the one thing that tyler
was hunting for he was indestructible he
couldn't be killed because that was the
power of claire she could heal from
anything so like in order to prevent
that future from happening that's why
hero went back in the first place to
stop this scenario where basically siler
conquers the world and so it's it's such
a crazy thing because it all leads to
the city of new york you end up having
this this whole thing where the guy who
can let off atomic explosions ends up
there as well peter absorbs his power
because he can't control whose power he
copies he absorbs his power and that's
when you realize peter's the one who
blows up new york accidentally and in
the in the five-year time skip that was
kind of the indication is that peter
somehow had something to do with that or
was somehow responsible for it or
something along those lines i don't
think it was explicitly stated that was
the case but like at the end of the
season you find out peter petrelli is
the one who blows up the city of new
york and so nathan and like this heroic
sacrifice like grabs peter petrelli and
flies into the air and then peter
petrelli basically detonates and it's
like okay like peter petrelli died like
syler escapes everybody kind of goes
back to doing their thing they're
largely on the run and then you got the
trailer for season two at comic con and
that was amazing but steve man heroes
like i basically just ruined the show
for anybody who hadn't seen it
hero season one was it was it's the
single greatest season of a comic book
show in the history of any comic book
show that's ever been written it's
better than loki wanda vision all that
stuff and there's a ton of stuff we left
out i mean it's just there's all this
stuff that goes on right it's just it's
one of the best shows ever don't watch
heroes like heroes return don't watch
that that was terrible watch heroes
season 1 and then stop and never watch
anything else because if you do it's
going to totally ruin the show for you
anybody who's ever watched all of heroes
will tell you the other seasons were
garbage the characters in the seasons
were cool but the other seasons were
trash right they were absolutely awful
oh that's the other thing yeah okay i'm
not even gonna ruin that the stuff that
horned rim glasses guy was making the
haitian do you guys remember that when
it came to like claire's family or mom
and all that kind of stuff it was nuts
right it was it was crazy how all that
was going down but the show's phenomenal
i will die
i will die on this hill heroes season
one is the single greatest comic book tv
show that has ever been made by anybody
ever it's not even really even based on
a comic it was just created by what is
it tim king or tim kring or whatever his
name is it was not based on a comic they
had comics that tied into it but it was
not based on a comic but hero season one
is the greatest comic book show that has
ever been created the greatest you know
superhero tv show ever made if you've
never seen it you need to go watch it it
is phenomenal with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end it's
literally just me ranting about like
about this whole thing we're gonna call
like we need to talk about like comic
book tv shows right we need to talk
about why comic book tv like all like
every show is bad i don't know what
we're gonna title this but like we're
gonna title something super clickbaity
but heroes was amazing right make sure
you guys go watch it but thank you all
for watching listen to me ramble for
however long and i will catch you all
later
peace